hello my name is Matt and welcome to
code Tecna toriel's today I'm going to
just show you just a quick thing it's
more of a resource how to get really
good at blender learn all the
fundamentals get good at ma 3d modeling
animating pretty much anything you can
do with blender I want to show you this
free awesome resource is really no
gimmick the only gimmick is I want more
views on my channel first blender org
look for their new 2.8 version you
download it set it up and get it going
I'm gonna go ahead and launch it looks
like this when you when you start it up
you go to youtube and just do a search
for blender and look for their main
channel this is it right here
oh then you want to go to playlists and
look for blender fundamentals 2.8
there's 26 videos here and they walk you
through everything you need to know to
get good at blender so if you want to
get into 3d modeling animating making
these kind of models for games or videos
or whatever it may be it's worth taking
the time I mean look these videos aren't
that long you could do this all in a day
but chances are the way most people
learn you need to do something at least
three times before it's set in your
memory what's really well so you're
really dedicated you could just plow
through this list as I know a lot of
people out there want to learn and use
blender but are just really intimidated
by all the options and this is the place
to be this little blender fundamentals
fundamentals list will really set you
off and good luck with your blender and
peace out